dude I feel I feel like I could fix her
I can change her yeah is she like Amber
herd fine not Amber herd fine she's
actually not she's not that fine I don't
want it like a Oklahoma 10 Oklahoma 9
that's like a hey muncher hey muncher so
now
[Music]
that did you guys hear about what
happened to former Major League Baseball
star Trevor Bower no no so he was
accused uh two years ago of sexual
assault by a
woman yes yes what did he I didn't
realize that was him yes what fill me in
guys it's major what did he do her so so
she she accuses him of sexual assault
right and then um she says that he beat
her up and all kinds of stuff like when
they were in bed and stuff like that
right he [__] her up and then [__]
her yeah and then and this all kinded
this kind of played out in the court of
public opinion for a while and then he
just just finally resolved his legal
case with her and basically exposed
everything on Twitter um just a couple
days ago yeah showing texts that she had
targeted him wow she says in her text
next victim star pcture for the Dodgers
no way she talks and she's talking to
her friend she talks about how much
money he is worth and how she is going
to go and get some of that W but does it
justify her getting beat up well she so
Trevor points out that there's video
that she took with him in bed the next
morning on the day that she claims she
was assaulted and she's totally fine she
pans the camera over you can see him
then she pans the camera overse her
she's like smiling and like has like a a
devious grin yeah being cute a little
devious grin on her face and then
proceeds to say that he beat the [__]
out of her releases photos of her I'm
not going to show them of her beat up of
her all beat up show us is that like uh
movie makeup then or um I don't know ex
sted yourself in the face or something
how that works but uh I'm just not going
to show them cuz I don't know but but it
so it was it during the whole like me
too cancel stuff that she jumped back it
was about two years ago I think that
that that kind of lines up with a lot of
that stuff right um it's to believe all
women time yeah but she um now that
these texts are out Trevor was sort of
not allowed to talk about this he
actually got kicked off his major league
baseball team cuz of Court [__] yeah
yeah he was um forced to play now in I
think he's playing in Japan um cuz they
have baseball over there which and they
condone violence for them they're down
with sexual assault so they're just like
yeah that makes sense oh this happen
every time all the time I see now this
is a normal this is a w the that's is
just a
kinky what that's not abuse that's a
kinky sex so now a lot of Tex play the
Tokyo are basically saying that holy
[__] like we yeah we shouldn't be so
quick to judge all the normal things
that people
say all the normal things oh maybe you
should [__] wait until the details
are out before you [__] burn a dude
yeah maybe not turn into a m immediately
I bet you all the all the [__] that
threw Stones though they're like don't
even remember they threw a stone they're
nowhere to be found and I bet you some
of them that are even doubling down and
saying well you know what every single
day women go through sexual assaults all
the time so well who cares yeah this is
just one victim of the other way the
crazy thing is that he can't even uh
like I guess people are saying like why
doesn't he sue her but he's like she's
broke there's no way that she could pay
him what he
lost there's no way that's what he talks
about in the video she'll never make
that money in her life like a Major
League Baseball even if she opened up a
only that's a little rude for you to if
major league baseball contract what if
you let her pick another victim yeah it
right all that and then you can get that
well she should get investigated because
it seems like she's a career con artist
right so how many other people have she
got away with cuz if she's talking about
next victim and if they don't find any
more baseball players check football
yeah she she also um one of her texts
was I'm going to his house Wednesday I
already have my hooks in damn she got a
system
dude how did they get her texts like
they just subpoena they had to subpoena
them but but the her legal counsel
blocked it and you know that once you
once you're in a suit with someone you
you have what's called Discovery you get
information like all the information she
supplied to her lawyers you get to check
out all that [__] right you get to look
through phones you get to look through
texts emails all that stuff anything
pertaining to the case so yeah these
texts were conveniently deleted real
quick they were conveniently deleted not
sent to his lawyers the lawyers noticed
the gap between like wait why did the
text stop here and continue here what's
between that and and that was her doing
that right it was her deleting it her or
or her team who knows and then how can
they can't find a deleted one you ask
T-Mobile and T-Mobile can bring it back
up you can't delete anything fully well
if you that's not true if you if you
take it drag it to the recycle bin gone
forever no but you have to actually
clear the trash bin though cuz that's if
you don't clear the the trash bid wait
what what what did she get from him
financially though nothing she got
nothing in the end this they were in
court to try to determine all that she
was attempting she was trying to get him
to settle yeah oh and he chose not to
because he was like I didn't do that
[__] but because he was in because he
was involved he still lost his contract
and everything like that that video of
her in bed with him and she's just like
it looks like she's like sending it to a
friend to be like told you got him [__]
so her friend so she says again part of
her for the preamble to all this stuff
she's texting your friend net worth 51
mil and then her and then um [__] you
better secure the bag that's her friend
said that so they're just all con artist
friends so there's a culture of this
thing that so now let me oh she also
says need daddy to choke me out um being
an absolute [__] to try to get in on
his 51 million dude I feel I feel like I
could fix her I could change her yeah is
she like Amber herd fine cuz if she is
she can get away with anything not Amber
Her fine she's actually not is she fine
though she just looks like a blondee
from like not really she looks like a
Saddle Ranch Nick and saver Saddle Ranch
she's not that fine I don't want it like
a Oklahoma 10 Oklahoma 9 oh no was that
La early 9 91 that's like a hay muncher
that's hay muncher so now that we've
raided this woman who's accused of
sexual assault wait can I see her um yes
it's very important that I have a vote
here I need to know my rating system
otherwise I can't participate ski
through the photos for all bruised if
that's okay with you show me the bru
yeah so you don't rate those also is
this like an anti-double Jeopardy where
it's like now the justice is she I'm not
going to say it I'm not going to say it
on huh no go ahead the justice is what
because she said she was a certain type
of abuse but then she wasn't so does
that mean some chicks are so fine they
just look innocent you know yep okay
that's he's guilty ding ding ding ding
ding like Amber herd yeah I'm not going
to lie she's still kind of fine you like
it yeah I'll be the judge of that as a
connoisseur of white women nah
dude she looks like she's in politics I
mean she's she's hot but she's not like
politics yeah she's not special that's
why I said kind of lindsy Hill Ryan if
you or who I think it's a bad angle okay
but if you go to Rodeo you probably find
like at least seven of her I it looks
like if I poured a little bit of water
on her it would all go away oh no that's
a bad one but she's not Jessica Simpson
fine though she's not Jessica Simpson
fine not Jessica Simpson and also she's
a hoe so let's talk about that so let's
talk about that so she recently came out
professional [__] on the defense and yes
she said she's a professional [__] no so
it says on Instagram bio she claims that
the video the next morning you couldn't
see her bruises cuz they haven't
developed yet that's how bruises work
stupid that's how they work and then she
says that um she was just joking with
her friend it was just for the ls and
like she's just a sick twisted [__] like
that yeah just like the way she's trying
to get settlement money a Twist six yeah
right that's her excuse that's what's
dangerous like it's like you just never
know who's trying to sink your their
claws into you that's why it's really
perfect to never have money you guys
ever heard of man Risa no he used to
play for the Minnesota Vikings he was a
punter I believe he was accused of
graping a chick and immediately jettison
from the team immediately kicked off the
team immediately loses his contract oh
my God so it took him same amount of
time about 2 years and now he was able
to clear his name prove that he was
never even at this party they claimed he
he graped this chick at and now no team
still has him on an active roster he has
life destroy black black listed just
completely not on the team yet he the
NFL teams need punters trust me I
watched last there's a shortage huh
there's there's a lot of teams that
could use a punter who could clear 40
yards yeah what about that college kid
where he he uh got acquitted and he
broke down and started crying because he
actually served time they ruined his
future there was like so many of the the
Duke lacrosse team nobody in the Sports
World does those like Hero Stories right
like like the The Comeback stories like
that for cuz it's still bad PR and they
don't really come back it seems like cuz
everyone's so scared of touchup but then
what happens to the people that are
creating these false accusations not
only false but fraudulent like don't
they go to how come they're not getting
now it's just like let's not listen to
them next time but then they have to
still because we're actually catching
them in the act of crime right so like
if this was a con artist and you caught
them clearly trying to dup somebody and
trap them do fraud they would be going
to jail for that so how come nothing's
happening is it because it's two
separate things where it's like this
case is about the case so even though
she's committing a crime through the r
case
she's got to have a separate case for
her you have to be willing to pay a
lawyer right like like you want to do
something you want but that's a criminal
case is what I'm saying is how come it's
not the state versus her I don't know
that's a great question what would the
charges be from the state the same
charges that you do abusing the legal
system when you no or like she used it
to but she used it to to extract money
and extort the guy so can't that be an
extortion case can't that be like yeah
but they might want to do that against
the juicy SM yeah because of you know
who what he might be but like to do that
against a like fairly attractive woman
that like again you would have to listen
to them the next time even if they you
know what I'm saying even if they lied
the first time it's like it's still just
a slippery slope even for the state
right it's bad PR it's want to ignore it
yeah may maybe it's easier to just sweep
that on you guys think the lawyers know
very easy you think the lawyers know
what like the the ones her lawyers yeah
the ones defending these chicks like
they got I feel like they got to know
look I've watched nine seasons of Suits
all right twice and every single time
and every single time right there's
always a moment where the client
neglected to say some information that
puts the corporate lawyer in a really
tough situation and they that corporate
lawyer chews them out but still goes now
I got to figure out how to fix this
another way yeah and walks out the door
all cool so the lawyers do know you
think they might they might be find out
they might innocently find out but it's
still their and they're also smart
enough to kind of know privilege right
the lawyer can't be like oh you are
guilty I have to turn you in you know
what I'm saying it's it's privileged I
think they also just do be going with it
anyway like me Ball's lawyer right now
what else are they going to do who
lawyer meatball that that girl that was
filming all the rioting in Philly and
was like participating it and stuff and
like the lawyer released a statement
saying oh no this is just the media
trying to vilify person of color or
something even though she was like
actively in the Looting oh Jesus and she
filming it yeah but even even Young
Turks was like and they're usually on
the other side even Young Turks was like
no [__] this
yeah it's like lawyers just do their job
they're getting paid whether they
[__] win or lose sometimes might as
well try yeah yeah they just got to not
look at it as personal it's still their
job and if they could just get it to a
settlement even then it won't be a loss
cuz pedals need representation too dude
someone's got to represent them yeah and
they're not called that anymore what do
we call them now minor attracted people
that's not going to catch on is it I
liked kid diders better kid ders I like
scumback I had like a roll to kid dler
kid dler yeah it's easy straightforward
it's good branding rolls off the tong
damn man believe all women
[Music]
though